[Music]
his own Secretary of Homeland Security
is admitting that we're going to have up
to 15 000 people coming in here legally
a day I think that if they don't have a
plan then they need to wait to end a
nation needs borders those borders
should be secure at the same time we
need some orderly process for
immigration
alarms are sounding from both sides of
the aisle now as a key deadline
approaches this upcoming week title 42
will expire at the southern border on
Wednesday of this week border agents
expect the number of illegal Crossings
to go from a 8 000 a day currently eight
seven to eight thousand to eighteen
thousand a day to Surge into America
after Wednesday that's an additional six
and a half million people a year as
President Biden refuses to acknowledge
the dangerous impact his policies have
had on American families last fiscal
year border patrol agents encountered a
record nearly 2.4 million migrants at
the southern border with up to 1 million
gotaways who have evaded apprehension on
Joe Biden's watch so that's five million
people illegally crossing on Joe Biden's
watch and another six and a half million
expected over the next year joining me
right now is Texas lieutenant governor
Dan Patrick and National border patrol
council president Brandon Judd German
it's great to have you here today thanks
very much for being here I want to get
both of your takes on what it looks like
today on the ground and how you're
expecting things to change come
Wednesday kick us off Dan Patrick
well you gave great numbers uh Maria and
Brandon knows what every person in law
enforcement knows if we apprehend 2
million a year maybe we apprehend one
out of every two or three that actually
cross so now you're talking about six
million a year plus the god of waves
that's 20 to 25 million people coming
here illegally now many are coming for
jobs but mixed in with them as Brandon
knows our terrorists we've caught our
criminals we've caught from rapists to
murderers to sex offenders fentanyl has
come in by the thousands of pounds the
number one killer of people 18 to 45 in
this country so when I hear the
Democrats say their own president
doesn't have a plan actually he does
have a plan he's allowing America to be
invaded our founding fathers thought
that no president would allow us to be
invaded but they saw an invasion as an
army with guns this is a different type
of invasion intended one day in the next
15 to 20 years to become citizens and to
become voters so the Democrats in their
view have a lock on this country forever
as a one-party system it's a danger
today on the street whether it's people
coming here up out of manhole covers
that we now hear from El Paso where the
Mayors declared a state of emergency so
he can get additional resources or it's
people in this country being harmed law
enforcement and the average citizens by
these people coming here illegally but
the real damage is to our democracy and
to our constitution in the long term
yeah and if you look at the an invasion
although this might not be an army it is
still being orchestrated by a organized
groups it's being orchestrated by the
cartels the golf cartel the Sinaloa
cartel they're orchestrating everything
that we're seeing on the border so yes I
absolutely do believe that this is is an
invasion and I do believe that we could
declare it as such but when you look at
what's currently going on you showed
some some staggering figures right now
you you look at the facts if we
considered effort being judged on
success then the cartels are working
extremely hard at their craft while the
the Biden Administration are doing
absolutely nothing the exact opposite
but if Everett is judged on lying in
deflection then the White House is
getting an A-Plus that's what we're
currently seeing right now they don't
care about the truth they don't care
about the facts they don't care that we
have already added to our population
just since he has been in office four
million people the people that we've
released into the United States and the
godaways when you look at The Crossings
the vast majority of the people that are
cross crossing the border illegally
they're being released into the United
States and that's the magnet that is
driving people to cross our borders and
that's how the cartels are making so
much money they're going throughout the
world and they're advertising their
services saying all you have to do is
give us thousands of dollars we'll get
you to the border and the Biden
Administration is going to release you
we can expect to continue to see this
because there are no plans operations or
programs in place right now to deal with
what's it what's expected
this is just extraordinary and you
mentioned bread in the cartels I went to
the Border five times as some of those
times I went embedded with you and your
team and I watched it up close firsthand
you just mentioned the cartels are they
making 300 million dollars at least a
week as I was told a couple of years ago
uh just on human smuggling I mean they
are getting rich and they are the ones
that are deciding who comes in and who
doesn't into America
yeah the profits are absolutely
staggering what we're seeing right now
when we approach when we seize 97
million dollars of drugs in 48 hours
that shows you how bad it is and then on
top of that if you if you count how much
the migrants are paying if you're from
Central America you're paying six
thousand dollars um to get into the
United States if you're coming from
China if you're coming from um countries
that are not um contingent to to our
continent then you're paying upwards of
thirty five thousand dollars these card
tells the the profits are staggering and
it's all based upon our policies we are
making them Rich President Biden is the
best friend to these cartels yeah you
just mentioned China yeah go ahead go
ahead governor no something that that
Brandon mentioned six thousand dollars
up to thirty thousand well where are
these poor people getting the money they
Scrabble together a little bit of money
but they become a new slave population
they come to America and they send their
money back to whatever country they come
from particularly in Central and South
America if they don't their families are
at risk so these people coming here will
be indentured servants to the cartels
forever and and also you have to
understand Maria that something that
Brandon just said they're lying to us
it's one thing when government lies but
it's another thing when they know
they're lying they know we know they're
lying and they don't care that's a
dangerous government indeed they know
they're lying people can see it for
themselves yeah and you know you look at
the change that has occurred throughout
Texas throughout Arizona I know that
these drugs get to big cities like New
York within 48 Hours you know the whole
country is dealing with the fentanyl but
Dan Patrick what can you tell us about
how Texas has changed and then Brandon
tell us about Arizona what you're seeing
on the ground and how this is impacting
our cities
sure from an electoral standpoint it's
turning the valley that was all Democrat
into a republican area number one
politically most of those folks were
down there were Democrats not long ago
they can't take it it's a Democrat mayor
in El Paso declared a state of emergency
secondly Maria the the president will
never answer this question where do
these people go what do they do where do
they go to live they don't have
citizenship now so they can't legally
get a job how do the kids go to school
they're two and three grade levels
behind if you put some 15 year old in
the fourth grade in an American school
well you can't do that because of age
differences so they they drop out of
school quickly which means how do they
make a living could go into a life of
crime so where do these people even go
these five million 10 million 15 million
during his four or eight years heaven
forbid he gets or more so where do they
go what do they do they become a blight
on society they're not help they're not
they're not a plus for our society which
immigrants coming here should be and at
the end of the day they don't care this
is a this is a cold-hearted
Administration they don't care about the
those people coming here the women are
getting raped the children into sex
trafficking it and they don't care about
the American population and they don't
care about Texas which I care about and
quickly I heard a Democrat on Fox
yesterday saying we're going to put 4
billion a year towards you know border
security we spend 4 billion a year
ourselves in Texas so therefore begging
from the federal government is a joke we
need and Brandon knows this is going to
take a massive effort of money and
Manpower we can do it with new
leadership in 24 and hopefully the
Republican Congress can slow down this
president but he's determined to
undermine this country
I I am so grateful that I'm not a
governor or lieutenant governor in Texas
or in Arizona right now what they have
to be dealing with is is is absolutely
monstrous but when you look across the
entire Southwest border the cartels
operate differently depending upon where
they're at the golf cartel they operate
in higher numbers lower cost that's why
everybody that's crossing the border
illegally are giving themselves up and
so Texas they have to bear the brunt of
all of that if you look at Arizona
you're you're dealing with the Sinaloa
cartel they're dealing with lower
numbers higher cost all of these people
are trying to evade apprehension they're
crossing the border illegally and
they're in camouflage they're not just
giving up they're trying to evade
apprehension those are the very
dangerous individuals and then on top of
it you look at what Texas is dealing
with Maria you've been down to the
Border I'm sure that when you went down
to the Border you you developed ideas on
what we could do to secure it yet we
don't have a president that's willing to
go down to the border to see firsthand
what's going on to try to develop some
ideas just extraordinary Texas
lieutenant governor Dan Patrick National
border patrol council president Brandon
Judd gentlemen thank you so much for
your leadership thank you and we will
brace for Wednesday's floodgates to open
we'll be right back
I'm Steve Ducey I'm Brian Kilmeade and
I'm Ainsley Earhart and click here to
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube page
to catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis